[Musique]
père noël j'ai vu des mosquées seulement
tu fais tes valises et à faire le web
est ce que tu as déjà vu le père noël
oui on joue à branches des refuges pour
mille dans la rue quand il veut il ya
une arme blanche avec une capuche rouge
un bâton rouge du vote rouge
ils veulent et à tête
trois coins
3 eyes et la tête où il habite le père
noël dans le ski est sur un bel âge on
se paye très froid à boulemane
il est marié avec qui
comment il s'appelle
elle est jeune ou les vieilles femmes
en bon
et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait pendant qu'ils
distribuent les jouer
saganash ce qu'ils mangent le choix aux
hommes de la troupe de la salade ni
froid là et un gâteau de fraises mais
comment il va faire pour venir du ciel
jusqu'à chez toi lots encore père le
camionnage
you avec un balai but je prends de
charette un traîneau ou alors qu'une
petite voiture où il ya des ficelles des
oiseaux qu'ils apprennent et bat pour
qu'il voit qu'il n'ya pas de parachute
et mais deux modèles wave google ou
monter sur son dos et qui décolle pour
aller pour qui les jouets et les patrons
faty nombre d'oiseaux la luano il
il est un peu fatigué pour ferrer mais
il veut défendre comme elle pourrait lui
porter chez les enfants les jouets
qu'ils apportent où il les a trouvés
scénique à sa maison les acheter en
magasin
une fois qui va terminer distribuer les
jouets qu'est ce qu'il fait et impôts
qu'il mais s'est dit peiné et vois pas
ce que font mes rêves bin moi
il repart même monté pour dépolluer
jouer pour qu'ils trouvent que l'on est
plus il va rechercher au point et demi
et puis on n'a pas toujours comment il
va rentrer chez toi un lapin et comment
il passe par la porte magique
eh ben ils passent par là ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas le toit comment il va par
là toi et on voit un mot sur toi et
après iront chez les enfants bien marché
il va pas
et s'il n'y a pas de cheminée moi j'aime
rim quand c'est pas noël
qu'est ce qui fait leur mal mais bon
c'est pas l'eau arrivait à pas avec cela
je connais ils ont eu peur aujourd'hui
des petites choses mais il les voit se
coucher le soir
les mecs comment tu sais tout ça
comme je peux faire réfléchir
[Musique]